from healthcare to finance to social
media data is helping businesses
innovate to a degree that was once
deemed unimaginable but at the same time
data also presents new challenges to the
developers who are trying to make it
useful
[Music]
there are many different factors to
think about when choosing a database
especially when you're dealing with
large amounts of data
maybe you're building a music
application that aims to recommend songs
to its users based on other music that
they like
initially your app may simply recommend
the top songs to users based on the
genre they listen to the most
but what if you want to take it a step
further and provide more personalized
song recommendations using machine
learning
what if your app went viral
these situations present new challenges
to your developers
the scale of your existing database
limits what you can do because of the
massive amount of data required to power
your music personalization algorithm
where can you find a database that
scales easily allows for large numbers
of reads and writes per second at low
latency and comes in a fully managed
service
this is where cloud bigtable comes into
play
bigtable is google cloud's fully managed
horizontally scalable nosql database
that is designed to support large
analytical and operational workloads
it's optimized for applications that
require large numbers of reads and
writes per second low latency and
performance at scale
let's take a look at several of the key
advantages of bigtable
first bigtable is fast and performant
it supports large numbers of reads and
writes with the ability to support
millions of requests per second
and it's able to do so with low latency
on the order of single digit
milliseconds
one potential application for bigtable
could be collecting global air quality
data from thousands of sensors
bigtable can handle the massive right
throughput generated and also be able to
read that data quickly and reliably
bigtable is also a highly scalable
database
throughput can be adjusted dynamically
by adding or removing bigtable nodes
a node is just a set of compute
resources that provides up to 10 000
additional queries per second and is
attached to additional storage capacity
there's no downtime when you change the
number of nodes so you can seamlessly
scale up to meet the demands of a large
batch workload and scale back down once
it's complete
thanks to the scalability bigtable
allows you to store up to petabytes of
data
this can be helpful if your application
is growing rapidly and you need to scale
quickly to meet the demands of new users
bigtable is also a fully managed and
reliable database
this allows you to concentrate on
building your application rather than
spending a lot of time fine-tuning the
database
data replication across multiple google
data centers ensures high availability
and low latency for users all around the
world
in fact bigtable recently joined cloud
firestore and cloud spanner with up to
99.999 availability sla
you can replicate your data by creating
new clusters a cluster is a big table
service in a specific location
bigtable is eventually consistent so
when you write a change to one cluster
you will eventually be able to read that
change from other clusters but only
after the change is replicated
bigtable also handles backups so you can
easily recover from application level
data corruption as well as human errors
bigtable integrates easily with popular
big data tools making it easy for
development teams to get started
it is support for the open source hbase
api standard making it easy to integrate
with the apache ecosystem including
hbase beam hadoop and spark
bigtable also integrates well with other
google cloud big data products like
bigquery dataflow and dataproc
[Music]
while cloud bigtable makes sense for
many use cases there are situations
where a different google cloud database
may make more sense
spanner is preferable if you need strong
consistency globally which makes it
better for transactions
it's also a sql database which is better
for more structured data
bigquery is an enterprise data warehouse
optimized for gaining organizational
insights from large amounts of
relational structured data
bigtable on the other hand is better for
applications that need high numbers of
reads and writes per second
cloud firestore is google cloud's
serverless nosql document based database
that makes it particularly easy to
integrate with mobile and web apps
it's a good choice if you need a
flexible data model with a guarantee of
strong consistency let's learn more
about bigtable's data model
bigtable stores data in massively
scalable tables that can scale up to
billions of rows and thousands of
columns
as nosql database bigtable stores data
and key value pairs stored in rows and
columns
each row represents a single entity
while each column contains values for
each row
columns that are related to each other
can be grouped into column families for
organizational purposes
at the intersection of each row and
column combination you can have multiple
cells with each cell representing a
different version of the data at a given
timestamp
this makes bigtable great for time
series analysis
bigtable tables are sparse meaning that
if a column is not filled in for a given
row it doesn't take up any space
if you're looking for a highly scalable
reliable and fast database to handle big
data workloads bigtable may be just what
your business needs try it out for
yourself by going to cloud.google.com
bigtable and stay tuned to hear more
about bigtable